listen man everything is uh very good
I'm going to say congrats on this movie
I've seen it twice uh yeah well I was
talking I did a long interview with John
and I wanted to make sure I could
actually like you know talk to him sure
sure well thank you man it's it's always
very very nice to see you Mike uh yeah
you know you're okay as an actor I'll
put up with you you could continue I'm
gonna make another movie I'm gonna say
that as a compliment yeah I might watch
um so I know I know you're a fan of
football so I'm just curious are you
watching AFC rex or no you're not
watching any uh British football no I'm
not a fan of football especially I know
I'm aware of what's happening with AFC
wrexham because uh it's big news in
Wales and
um I mean to say I know Ryan Reynolds
would be a stretch but we've met and we
follow each other on Instagram and it's
an amazing cool thing
um whilst I'm not much of a fan of
football I am a real fan of Ted lasso
though and um obviously all those
episodes have just dropped which is what
I'm going to be spending my weekend
doing I've seen the first two episodes
uh they're they're what we call kind of
good I think that show's gonna it's
gonna be okay good good that's good to
hear I really it really has its hooks in
me that show yeah the second episode is
tremendous uh but anyway enough about
you know Ted lasso last time we spoke
you I asked you if you were planning on
directing and you said there was
something you were thinking about it's
been like a year I think or give or take
so any other plans on directing no I uh
no
um I have just uh uh
I I did since we last spoke I did secure
an option on a book which happened yeah
well I'm very familiar yes I won't be
directing Happy Head
um but I do intend to be a very Hands-On
creative producer
um and I think that feels like a healthy
step
towards the creative nucleus
of sort of Storytelling if that's not a
horrendously pretentious turn of phrase
and I hope that the lessons I begin
learning through more active grounds up
producing will equip me for an eventual
step into directing but I'm not enough
of a grown-up yet but the time will come
and I think I'll know when it's right
because it will feel like a story that I
have to tell
um and you know maybe I would start by
perhaps directing shorts that's
something that I've thought about I have
a loose idea for something and also it
has occurred to me that perhaps
directing
I don't know I shouldn't even say that
actually that's something I should keep
to myself because I'm oversharing but
yeah I'd still love to do it sure I was
going to say you could also start with
an episode of Television that has a
format that you can sort of that's what
I was about that's what I was about to
say yeah yeah I mean it I figured you
were going in that direction when we
last spoke it was for Blackbird which
you know I was a huge fan of what has it
been like watching you know Paul won
some awards yeah and the show was very
successful what was it like you know
having something that people really
really enjoyed yeah it's amazing to be
involved with anything that people are
that effusively praising about is uh is
an extraordinary feeling
um
oh I I I I well my part was always
fairly certain that was going to happen
because I had front row seats to that
performance and it's an extraordinary
one
um and I'm fiercely proud of him
um and I just feel
very secure in a job well done that and
there's no better feeling than a job
well done
um and uh Dennis lehane who is the
creator of that show and somebody that I
have loved working with has
been very kind in that he has offered me
the the lead in his next project as well
which is something we will be embarking
on later in the year
and whilst I can't say anything about it
because it's well at least of all
because it's in the process of being
created it's a completely different role
for me and a very fresh Challenge and
and I think in some respects
I think it could feel like a kind of
sister piece to Blackbird which is cool
um so I'm very excited about that too uh
it's been an amazing journey Blackbird
and it and it it goes on you know Paul
and I were recently celebrating the show
at the SAG Awards where we run both
nominated and it's just amazing when
something takes on a life that sustains
that long you know and uh yeah it's
really it's really really great people
have
really seem to have enjoyed it Matthew
Vaughn has literally changed your life
in in given been part of some of a lot
of roles for you what do you actually
get him as a gift like at Christmas well
I you know I try and not be bad in the
films she puts me in is the main thing
the thing about Matthew as well I mean I
don't know who you know this Matthew is
a phenomenally wealthy man so he's one
of those people you can't really buy
gifts for but uh he was
50 last year and um
I didn't know what to get him and I got
him a framed
set still from about 10 years ago just
on the tech well about nine years ago in
fact and it was the scene in the first
Kingsman where I am strapped to the
track in one of the kingsman test
exercises and he stood over me in a
Parker directing me but he's directing
me in quite an emphatic way so it kind
of looks like he's a villainously
loading it over me as I'm tied to a
train track so I got him that for his
50th
um I think when somebody you know you
try and buy a gift for somebody who has
everything the best thing to do is try
and tap into some sort of sense of
sentiment I think so that's what I did I
know Matthew and I also know he likes
whiskey and uh the problem is what do
you mean I ain't buying a bottle of
whiskey that Matthew's gonna enjoy I do
fine but I ain't spending nothing
I have a story for you at another not on
camera
um but still jumping into Tetris uh this
is such a effing crazy story and I think
that even if you read Wikipedia you
won't you won't think this is true but
it all is for people that don't realize
this is a wild crazy true story how much
and I know it's so cool so generic but
how much did you know and how much were
you surprised it was actually real well
yeah that was the I mean I didn't know
any of it and that was the thing that I
was most concerned with when Matthew
first sent me the script was I wanted to
know what was fact and what was fiction
and
approximately 40 more of it was back
than I thought it would be the biggest
embellishment is probably the last scene
of the movie where there is a kind of
quite High updating Chase but in terms
of the machinations of these separate
factions trying to win rights in a uh a
very volatile place at a time of
particular political unrest
is all true even down to the fact that
um Hank Robert Stein and um
Maxwell the younger
Kevin Maxwell
um all turned up a log on the same day
is true so
uh yeah I mean if you were to put a
crude percentage on it I think 85 95 but
it's true yeah John was saying I think
the next book to Alexi and Hank then
they basically said that the movie is uh
more
um I'm gonna say this it feels like it's
it's happening much faster yeah it's
more condensed right yeah that's what
I've that's what they're trying to like
it it happened over a longer period of
time but it's all except for the car
chase it's basically true yeah and I
believe even the culmination at that
very significant event of the of the
falling of the Berlin War you know
um
is all fairly true as well I think so
yeah exactly that for purposes of a
three-act story things are more
condensed together
but the Bare Bones of it is is all
factor I know you get offered a bunch of
scripts what was it actually about this
project that said oh I want to do this
well I just done Rocket Man and I was
signed on to do Blackbird and I think I
felt that Hank the role of Hank on the
page was and was a sort of
was a nice counterpiece that is my
selfish motive for wanting to do it but
I I just love the story I found it
utterly compelling and I couldn't
believe it was true
and also I knew John's work and I
obviously know Matthew's work and I knew
that their vision for it was going to
have a sense of fun and kineticism that
would appeal to that kind of gamer
nostalgic audience you know it was
divided up into chapters that would sort
of
um crude representations of the process
of engaging in a game so start pick a
player all that stuff and I just thought
it felt Poppy and fresh and fun and
would find a really solid audience and
so I hope that's what happened you get
to wear that mustache in the movie yeah
when you wore that like into the
reaction with that plus Dash did you
leave said it all wearing that and did
you get to be anonymous or people still
knew who you were no that I mean I was
insistent on doing that because I mean I
don't grow a very strong mustache so I
had to wear a fake one but
um
when I did Eddie the eagle I wore one
for a few scenes and it got to the point
even though what was probably only about
three weeks of wearing it that I would
arrive on set in a perfectly chipper
happy mood put on that mustache and
instantly become an unpleasant person to
be around because it's awful it
really is awful I can't I mean Toby
Jones said to me on set he said I can't
believe you're doing that I've done it
myself it's the worst thing in the world
and it's it's I mean look first world
problems but it's just very
uncomfortable
and itchy and there's just something
about having something in the front
middle of your face that really puts you
in a bad mood
um so I can't believe that in the Years
between Eddie the eagle and Tetris which
was probably about
five or six years in terms of production
dates that I forgot how uncomfortable it
is and deign to wear one for an entire
shoot
you know I cannot forget the discomfort
of it again because it was it was pretty
horrendous but
it's a strong look and it's how hang
looked and I wanted to create his look
and um you know I had to have a little
bit of help
above and beyond what time what nature
gave me you know I'm glad you wore it
and I'm uh just because it does it makes
you look the character yeah you know
yeah what's funny is you say all this
now but down the road someone's gonna
offer you a role where you have to wear
facial hair again and you're gonna say
yeah I'll do that
the thing is it's sort of final round
here under here but it's just there it's
quite weak
um but unfortunately sometimes that's
the bit you need and that was the case
you think you know completely
um I found it that it was so interesting
that you filmed this movie in Scotland
uh and I believe uh Abba when I wrote
this down Aberdeen
um which had the architecture for Russia
I don't think they've made movies in
these places so what was it like filming
where people are not used to watching a
movie like this what happened in it but
I think is somewhere that uh when I
don't know what's been filmed there in
the past but it certainly didn't feel
like it was a common occurrence and
people were very excited we were there
John the director is also from Aberdeen
so that added a certain sort of sense of
fun to the proceedings but it was it to
be honest you know this was at the end
of 2020
I'd been sat in my apartment between the
months of March and
August September
um so it was just very very exhilarating
and exciting to be back making a movie
um and yeah it was great being in
Scotland it's a terrific uh terrific
place with amazing people and even in
the midst of a covid lockdown I just had
an incredible time in in both Glasgow
and Aberdeen
um just wandering around and getting
familiar with those uh towns uh Matthew
told me that he is uh hard at work on a
number of things but you know Kingsman
is a part of it yeah so have you spoken
to him about another one is it yeah
um yeah I mean I don't know what I
should say really I
be careful with what you say but tell me
what you can yeah I mean I
so I you know I so
I haven't I have an idea for Kingsman I
haven't I have my own idea that I would
like to pitch to Matthew
um and I think that will be happening
soon but he has a he has he has the
wheels in motion on a big idea of his
own
um so who knows you know who knows where
it will land but he has every intention
of making it oh and if you're and I have
every intention of playing actually
one more time that was always what I
thought I was committed to doing
um
I just it's the it's the role that it's
the role that made my name so I suppose
in a way
I just want it to be absolutely right
if we do it again and I want the story
to be I want the story to to do to do
justice to to the part that really
changed my life
um and I I wanted to be a fitting ending
so
um
and I would obviously really hope that
Colin would would come back or at least
a part of it and um who knows we'll have
to see you know but we are planning to
talk about it actually the next time we
see one another so who knows watch this
space but
you know he's certainly not um he's
certainly not backing off the idea oh
yeah I'm I am well aware and also with
the whole uh Kick-Ass thing he has a lot
going on um well you know anyway on that
note listen congrats on Tetris always
great talking with you like otherwise
nothing but the best cheers mate it's
always really lovely to see you thank
you